Now that we have some sense of what things are slightly different and
more complicated and we need to be concerned with geographic data,
even with something as fundamental as the file type,
we're going to start building our map step by step in D3.
As you can see here,
the familiar skeleton of code that we've always started with.
Here is our function named draw that takes a single argument geo_data, named, so
because this function's actually going to get passed our GeoJSON at the bottom.
Notice, rather than loading our TSV of World Cup data,
we're simply loading world_countries.json,
a GeoJSON file that contains the outlines of all the countries.
Since we are displaying a map of the entire world,
there are ready GeoJSON data files for many common geographies.
The most common being the entire world and the US.
So I was able to find a GeoJSON of all the world countries online.
If a GeoJSON file does not already exist of the region you would like to
visualize you can use a few different utilities to convert
shape files into GeoJSON.
There's a few resources and
tutorials in the instructor notes of this video, which can show you how.